why don't we go next to
I hope I pronounce this correctly is it
tiku in Los Angeles California tiku
tiku welcome to the program please
accept the invitation to join
uh I'm here welcome what's on your mind
today
uh so I have been uh listening for quite
some time uh since uh last year and uh
I've noticed that a lot of the callers
uh tend to be men and I was wondering if
just like by way of data or insights
from being in the industry if you have
any uh Insight on why that may be yeah
shows like mine The Young Turks and
others
have significantly larger male audiences
than they do female audiences it's in
all of the demographics it applies to
all of our shows even shows like this
with female co-hosts still have
overwhelmingly male audiences and that's
reflected in the callers I think and and
part of it is
what what the demographic data seemed to
show is that women are less likely to
get political analysis from online
left-wing Independent Media shows than
men are
interesting yeah okay uh and then uh a
final question just for you as a media
professional I wanted to hear kind of
even though this is sort of politics
adjacent uh your take on uh the strikes
that are happening
the the late night writers right well
listen we we actually talked about this
on the award-winning and world famous
bonus show earlier in the week
um the the thing about the the strikes
is
the demands are obviously they're they
were not able to come to an agreement
over salary but it's really more
complicated than that and so much of the
uh money being made on these programs is
now coming on the back end through
archives and streaming and asynchronous
viewing and writers don't typically have
a provision in their contract that
compensates them for that so they are
saying now that the initial audience
that watches it live on TV is only a
fraction of the total audience since we
don't get any of the back end we need
more money up front I think that's a
totally legitimate claim it's a reality
about the changing media landscape so I
think they're they're completely uh uh
correct in uh their desire to be paid
more upfront
great well thanks for taking my call I
also don't watch any of those shows so
it really doesn't bother me if they're
off the air
there you go all right tiku thank you I
appreciate the call
sure what is that finish is that a
Finnish name
uh no uh it's the name my mom made up
because it's easier for Americans to say
than my actual name oh okay all right
fair enough all right do you from Los
Angeles Crystal Clear thank you very
much appreciate that why don't we go
next to Patrick from Vancouver Patrick
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
hello David uh how are you sir I'm
coming to you with tears in my eyes
enough to flush the toilet 10 to 15
times
very good
uh I am wondering about today about your
opinion about um ESG investing
well I mean so won't ESG investing for
people who don't know is investing that
takes into account the environmental and
social impact of the companies that you
are investing in
um generally speaking you know there's
two views on this one view is if you
focus on ESG
you're going to get an inferior return
because the most profitable companies
may not adhere to whatever is sort of
like En Vogue at the time in terms of
adhering to environmental and social
issues so it's a perfectly fine way to
invest but you're just going to have a
lower return the the increasing
Counterpoint is that over the medium to
long term the most profitable companies
will be the ones that are
environmentally and socially conscious
so that actually it's the best of both
worlds you're doing a good thing morally
and ethically and you're also going to
get the highest return honestly my view
on this is not a morality view it's
informed my but my by My Views generally
on investing which is I don't think I'm
good at picking stocks I don't think
most people are good at picking stocks
I'm going to invest in the broadest
index that I can
ESG index funds but like the problem is
like their management fees are
significantly higher the high management
fees but my view on this Patrick is if
over time
the core all companies in in a country
are going to move more in the direction
of stricter environmental and social
standards by investing in the broadest
possible Index Fund over time I'll get
more exposure to that ESG aspect anyway
okay
so it's just it'll just the market the
market like for like you know for
something like I don't know an S P 500
Index it'll just adjust over time I
would go even much broader I I would go
with a total stock market index yeah
okay
so like I shouldn't feel bad about say
investing currently right now in a in
like you know a total stock market
that's a different question whether you
should feel bad or not I can't tell you
maybe you do feel it I mean listen you
know Noam Chomsky was confronted a few
years ago and they said you know you
make all these criticisms about
corporations and all these different
things the environment and social
responsibility but then you've got your
retirement money in the same index funds
everybody uses and chomsky's response
was basically like listen I'm an
activist for the things that I believe
are right but at the end of the day am I
going to keep my money under my mattress
that doesn't make any sense there are
obviously more options now than just
mattress or oil stocks but uh you know
that's chomsky's View
thank you very much sir all right my
friend thank you very much for the call
uh always
um always great to hear from our friends
to the north I'll be back in Canada soon
it'll be extraordinarily exciting I'm
sure